[Musique]
t'inquiète pas villageoise j'ai pas de
faire de mal
je voulais juste provoquer l'autre
clochard de belle-ile d'accord ok ok
attend c'est beaucoup plus clair là pour
moi parce que depuis tout à l'heure je
me dis le mec est fou il arrive de nulle
part une kidnappe genre c'est normal et
c'est normal je suis seigneur te
kidnappe si je fais le droit de cuissage
c'est la loi je suis le seigneur
ok d'accord ouais ben alors dit allons-y
quoi allons-y l' affaire qu est ce que
tout ce qui était avec moi mais non je
ne veux pas eh ben on fait part
non on fait pas mais si je voulais
onfray hockey est en excuse moi là ça va
trop vite en train de vous je suis
désolé c'est pas toi c moi c'est sûr
mais ça me fait écho à des trucs que je
n'avais pas du tout entre eux mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on s'engueule comme si
on était un couple alors qu'on n'est pas
du tout un coup tu vois et moi je
m'étais promis de ne jamais plus robuste
en apparence et je veux mieux s'exprimer
distance sur constat corps donc ça n'a
rien à voir a plutôt bien tenté
[Musique]
non mais je suis désolé dit déchire un
truc j'ai pas réfléchi
enfin que je le fasse parce que sinon
ils disent et les grilles j'étais en
train de dire bien ça c'est rien comparé
à ce qui est en train d'arriver assez
pour geneviève terrifiés depuis même
faut arrêter à vigy guerre complètement
fou bon heureusement je connais leur
passage secret qui nous mènerait
directement la salle du trône un passage
que seulement et quelques livreur de
bouffe on connaît le souci c'est qu'ils
connaissent pas face tu vas avoir besoin
d'un costume très bien tu as le costume
maintenant il faut que tu rentres dans
la peau du personnage elle est immonde
ta phrase il faut que tu sois quelqu'un
que tu n'es pas ok bonjour je suis un
gros l'âge de moines qui fait des
positions un peu plus au nom du 802 une
tune sur ses voisins exacte et reconnaît
grübel était très spécifiques non mais
il faut pas que mimiques moi il faut que
tu inventes un personnage qui n'existe
pas comme un paysan un céréalier les
laisser là c'est très mauvais c'est très
très mauvais je pense que le mieux c'est
que tu parle pas du tout
[Musique]
nouveau toit oui ça c'est vraiment du
lot complot et toi c'était vraiment si
penser que ça de me tuer tu veux
vraiment le faire là maintenant sur la
table ça seul et sexuelle sexuelle mais
bon une dernière volonté
oui tranchant la gorge avec un tesson de
bouteille refusé à dieu b lire quoi je
te défie ans tu es tu dises hier non
mais arrête avec ça je t'ai dit j'ai
changé maintenant les duels ça se passe
avec des bouchées on allume deux bûcher
et celui qui brûle pas y gagne j'accepte
attend quoi tu as très bien entendu
c'est vrai ça me fait tellement plaisir
tu vas cramé mais ça me fait super
plaisir
je pensais que jamais personne avec ses
traits sa demande juste une chose à
hélice
ouais je veux pouvoir me préparer dans
la chaumière il n'y a pas de souci je te
colle de soldats au cul je garde la
villageoise en otage et si jamais essayé
de fuir je la butte ça va ça a abondé le
fils de [__] plaisir je veux te prendra
pas de poulet but le ok voici les yeux
mais enfin pourquoi tu as demandé ça je
sais pas moi la dingoo plate est
opérateurs n'importe quoi pour sauver ma
peau alors temps pour sauver sa peau du
mondial au budget rebbah c'est le
premier truc qui vient à l'esprit piché
qu'il adore les bouchers est-ce que tu
as conscience qui veulent jeter dans les
flammes
oui oui justement tu me disais qu'avec
ta science tu avais peut-être à faire
des flammes qui brûlent parents lui ben
euh non non le feu ces feux je peux pas
nommer une fois tu avais réussi à faire
depuis qu'ils aient décliné c'était de
la note mais cabinet une solution si je
peux être une potion d'invulnérabilité
mais attention c'est temporaire
ces impasses une plante très rare qui
s'appelle le secr ire axe hurel comme
importe peu importe j'ai plus que toi
d'accord si tu arrives à faire cette
posture et que ça marche on arrivera à
prouver à tout le monde qu à 17 gros
connard et qui est sur le trône pour de
mauvaises raisons
comme ça je récupérer mon pouvoir sauver
le royaume prendrai jamais 123 ça se
tente
j'aurais oui tu peux le faire
merde
[Musique]